there was an item yesterday that caught
some attention specifically the
attention of hashtag Tommy himself Gary
Myers long-term reporter for the New
York Daily News tweeted this tom was
worn out by josh josh mcdaniels after
all these years that surprised me
worn out by the offensive coordinator
not the head coach and gary myers cites
an excellent source not to be confused
with the non excellent sources I'm
always vouching for one specific source
because it implies that all my other
sources stink but at least in this case
Gary Myers source doesn't stink his
source is excellent that Tom Brady and
Josh McDaniels found that their
relationship had deteriorated over the
years now there is one person Kris who
would say that the source is not
excellent and that would be Tom Brady
himself who actually took an image of
our story written by Michael David Smith
managing editor pft based upon Gary
Myers tweet took a photo of that and
that did whatever it is that you can do
on Instagram to write over top of it
please stop this nonsense mr. Brady said
please be more responsible with
reporting 19 years together and brothers
for life heart emoji at real Josh
McDaniels Chris you worked there you've
got connections there you tell me what's
going on I thought that the
deterioration was with the relationship
with Bill Belichick not Josh McDaniels I
was surprised by the report from Gary
Mann Gary Myers so was Tom Brady
what say you well what I say is you know
one I I don't think these relationships
are bad and you know I don't know if
deteriorating is there the right way to
say it either you know and again you're
right
I know people up there I know a lot of
people around the league that used to
work there and still know the guys up
there so I do hear tidbits from New
England from time to time from my
friends around the league you know and I
think the big thing to me is I don't
think there's like
an issue here where they're like Oh
Jacque you know Thomson they're going
I'm never gonna talk to Josh McDaniels
again and McDaniels is all I'm sick of
Brady I don't want to deal with him
anymore no but do I think the
relationship was exhausted a little bit
yeah I do I do I have heard Inklings of
that over the last two years up there in
New England
whether it was Brady and Belichick or
you know not not necessarily that I
heard McDaniels and Brady or anything
along those lines but McDaniels and
Belichick are very similar people as far
as the way they approach the job on a
daily basis I mean there's a reason
McDaniels has been there that long have
been that successful and even when he
left bill takes him back I mean he's a
little bit of a mini bill in a lot of
ways and from Tom's angle and we've
heard a lot of this I mean this is the
reason I don't think Tom showed up to
the last two OTAs for the last two years
of oth to the New England Patriots
I think he's worn out by everything in
New England New England's brutal it is
brutal and I think Tom Brady got to a
point in his career where you know hey
he's going I got enough Celts on the
horse or I've done you know got enough
you know badges on my coat or whatever
it may be to where he doesn't want to be
micromanaged and looked after for every
little thing he does in the world and in
New England they just don't give a damn
they don't care if you're Tom Brady and
you won ten Super Bowls or if you're you
know Jared situm and you haven't done
crap yet they really hold your feet to
the fire on a daily basis and I think
that's where a lot of this talk comes
from and you know what you're saying
makes sense for a couple of reasons
first of all Bill Belichick isn't going
to want anyone working for him who
doesn't adapt and adhere to the patriot
way which means you are going to be a
lot like Bill Belichick you are going to
be withholding affection withholding
praise being leery about possibly
inflating your players heads by puffing
them up with unnecessary
attaboys and whatnot so you have to be
like Bill to survive how many times have
we seen guys leave New England and
they're just like Belichick and it fails
including Josh McDaniels
hey all these guys leave and even when
they say they're gonna do it their own
way like Matt Patricia did when he left
for the Lions a couple of years ago
these guys don't realize how much their
DNA has been altered by extended
stretches with Bill Belichick you think
they're being your own guy but the
baseline perspective is always Bill
Belichick your own twist on Bill
Belichick but still at your core you're
Bill Belichick so to the extent Tom
Brady had a problem with the Patriots
had a problem with Belichick had a
problem with McDaniels had a problem
with the whole system the whole way
right that's really the big takeaway
here if it's going to deteriorate with
Belichick it's gonna deteriorate with
McDaniels it's gonna deteriorate with
everyone on the coaching staff the
interacts with agreed and you know
that's where you know first off Gary
Myers is not a guy that like just throws
out splash BS right and we're nor is he
in the business of trying to break
stories all the time so you know one for
him to say these type of things makes me
think that somebody's led them in that
direction right but I don't think this
is like Oh Brady's and Brady and
McDaniels hate each other they're never
gonna talk to each other again or
anything uh I think this is just
professional tired um blur whatever you
know I'm making up English language as I
go here yes some are yeah but but you
know within that toe to accentuate what
you said Mike right you know it does the
building is Bill and you know that from
the second you pull up in that parking
lot in New England and the second you
walk through that door now I know
they've changed the facility a little
bit but when you walk through the door
you have to walk by bears Najarian who
is Bella checks right-hand man and that
sets the tone right there because
they're serious and you might walk by
Bill and you know he's gonna be at work
and ready to go and a curmudgeon so the
whole day the attitude of the building
is always set by Bill through and
through and yes you know again you can
even talk to you know when I heard about
this and then I go oh you know hey Tom
had some issues that he wanted more say
and the offensive game plan and things
like that you know listen they'll listen
to Tom up there but again if this is
their ship bill is the commander
doesn't matter so josh is gonna go in
there and he's gonna build off building
an offense a game plan for the week but
he's already conversating with bill
about how they want to attack that team
and what they want to do which fits best
fits their own team going forward and
all those things so we're yeah they're
gonna listen to Brady but at the end of
the day Bella check the McDaniels go
we're oh we're here in this building for
like 120 hours every week we're gonna be
the ones that come up with a game plan
and Dean what's necessary to be in there
and not be in there and you know I think
probably Brady got sick and tired of
that crap too because he probably felt
like he's earned the return to have
enough respect to add more input into
the game plan in a weekly basis and I
love issues like this that become
transferable to other workplaces other
dynamics I mean McDaniels is the guy
who's caught between his boss and his
favorite employee and at some point
there will be deterioration in the
relationship with the employee if the
guy in the middle is choosing to cater
to the guy who's responsible for his pay
his career the possibility that he
someday will succeed Bill Belichick look
you got to take care of your own
interests at some point and in this
relationship you gotta side with the
boss you can't side with the guy who
reports to you because the boss is the
one who's ultimately making all the big
decisions and you aspire to be there for
an indefinite period of time and again
maybe succeed the boss at some point so
this one's a no-brainer whatever
affection josh mcdaniels may have for
Tom Brady that doesn't mean he's gonna
start doing things differently just
because Tom Brady is getting worn out by
the Patriot way no no yeah because the
last thing that ship is gonna tolerate
is a mutiny
because Bill's right well both of them
overboard in a heartbeat Chris yeah
you're exactly right it just it's not
gonna work there you know it's not and
it's just it's the most detailed
well-thought-out place in the NFL and
you know again I say this a lot but
there's a reason they've dominated the
league for the last 19 years I mean they
have a process in which they believe in
and it starts in OTAs and again I think
that's why there's you know this
perceived friction or maybe things just
didn't end up you know with the better
row
and everything like that because I think
Brady's in the fact that he didn't show
up in the last two OTAs hey that's where
New England and even my experience
working for Josh McDaniels in Denver and
OTAs it's where the team starts it's
where they start to go okay let's
reevaluate our team it's a new team this
year we have some new pieces here how
are we gonna build going forward and
they take it kind of piece by piece day
by day and they build it from there and
they're not going to vary it from
anything for anyone because I think you
know they believe in their system and
that's why it's worked you know also the
other thing I always heard Mike up there
too it's just that at times there was
you know a reluctance from Brady at
times to want to add more into the
offense right just hey simplify it
protect me get somebody open and that's
all there is to it
I've heard a lot of that kind of talk
over the last two years I don't know if
that's true or not but I think it all
just goes back to the same thing that
the relationship just went on for a long
long time that a lot of great years
they're competitive they work hard and I
think you know it just fizzled out a
little here and they'll kind of
reconnect when their careers are over
and when Tom's career is over you know
the beauty of your shotgun approach to
the English language is every once in a
while you'll twist I hit it right into a
word that actually is a word variation I
had to check is not doubted something
out that sounds ridiculous but it's like
holy crap it's it's actually a word also
I we got to be careful apparently about
using the word crap one of our friends
in the UK told me yesterday that and I
haven't researched this yet but for now
crap means crap on any continent all
right let's have a temporary moratorium
on using the word crap until we can
confirm that it isn't as bad as the s
blank-blank T word in the UK and in
Ireland because that could get us into
some deep crap if we're not careful so
III think I think we've kind of
harmonized all this then the bottom line
is Tom Brady
is sick of the Patriot way and I don't
know that sick a sick up may be too
strong
Tom Brady had had enough of it he just
had enough he had reached the time limit
of dealing right and and you know what
one of the realities of getting older
and those of you out there who are
fortunate enough to be old like me you
will realize as to certain people as to
certain things as to certain foods as to
certain TV shows as to certain anything
you will reach a point where you have
decided that's it I've had enough for my
entire life I'm good I don't need to
deal with this person anymore
I don't need to go to this restaurant
anymore I don't need to go to this place
anymore I don't need to watch this show
anymore I'm good I have reached my
lifetime limit best example for me
firework shows I don't need to go to
another firework show I've seen them all
I know what it looks like I know what it
sounds like it no longer does anything
for me I've seen it too many times Chris
that's kind of what Tom Brady has
reached with the Patriots he has reached
his lifetime limit of dealing with that
system in that organization yeah I I do
I understand that you know I was gonna
use peanut butter and jelly for my
example because that you know I went
through my mom packed me peanut butter
and jelly every day for lunch for like
nine years in a row and I got to high
school and I was like man I can't look
at P Navarre and jelly ever again the
rest of my life I've been needed every
day and I had to take like a six-year
hiatus from it now it's back to being
delicious again so I do understand it
and again with with these alpha type
males as competitive as they are as
driven as they are the stress your
stress you're under as a OC a head coach
a quarterback all those things hey I
think it's completely natural after this
long of a relationship to have it fizzle
out or just be worn out and wants
something new a little bit I think
that's really all we're hearing here and
doing good well but hey
thank you Tom Brady thank you josh
mcdaniels ultimately thank you Gary
Myers for giving us something to lead
the show with because it's a little more
challenging this time of year than it is
during actual football season
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports